oh my god there's like an arrangement
everywhere look at that
oh my god nothing like kids to keep you
humble
and that's just what kim kardashian's
daughter northwest
did she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
the kkw beauty founder celebrated her
40th birthday recently
and on wednesday she hit up instagram to
show off some of the gorgeous floral
arrangements
she got from a few famous pals
oh my gosh don't read all the cards
i wonder i know natalie and olivia sent
me the 40.
look at the flower shop hey hey hey
don't eat my cake please
that looks good so i can't eat that cake
yeah northy reached for that kim cake
but it was
this savage moment that has people
talking olivier
i love you so much look at these
beautiful flowers
they go all around my table
wow really not good
they are so i love this color i'm dying
these are no you're not so or you're
being the great
it's like an expression i know so north
not impressed with beaumont creative
director olivier rousting's arrangement
olivier i love you so much look at these
beautiful flowers
they go all around my table
really not bad they are so i
love this color and the sass didn't stop
there
okay so i walk into my bathroom oh my
god there's like an arrangement
everywhere oh my god
why that's how i feel because it's
bad chrissy teigen also sent over a
massive and i mean massive bouquet
and the seven-year-old was right by her
mom's side to throw a little
shady sarcasm chrissy oh my god chrissy
you guys chrissy tegan can you
like what is this that is actually
flowers you know
awesome it's just so awesome
hi everyone in california it's kim
kardashian west and i just wanted to
talk to you and northwest of course this
isn't the first time north has given her
famous mama a hard time
got the most beautiful weather but we
have to start to train ourselves
you went outside in your backyard and
that's totally fine back in april
she straight up crashed kim's stay at
home psa
it's really important to also do mental
health checks on your friends and your
loved ones you're busy of your kids
not your friends facts
oh and who could forget when kim tried
to film a makeup tutorial while
quarantining at home with her hubby
kanye west and their four kiddos
i'm hiding in the guest room because my
kids
will not leave me alone hey that's me
yeah north was there too and can i just
say
hiding from your kids in the bathroom is
a mood
north can i please just do my little
tutorial i i
it's all i want to do is one little fun
thing for myself